i want to go to mustafa he's the
secretary general of the palestinian
national initiative he's joining us via
skype from ramallah so thank you very
much indeed for being with us um
the circumstances are as we were saying
extremely vague at the moment with
regard to this shooting
there is a suggestion by the israeli
military the palestinian gunmen may be
held responsible for this we don't know
we can't obviously establish the
background to what happened what is
going to be the palestinian reaction in
the event that it is discovered there is
a possibility that palestinian
government may have been involved in
this
well first of all our deep condolences
to the family of sherina barack
has always been a
fantastic correspondent a fantastic
journalist and i would call her she's
the martyr of the truth
she tried always to present objectively
the truth about reality in palestine our
deep condolences also to al jazeera
because she was the correspondent of al
jazeera tv
but to be honest with you and i hope you
will excuse me for saying that i don't
think that your
coverage is really being objective i
think you're buying the israeli story
too much
and the israeli narrative is absolutely
wrong here we know the facts we know the
facts from the colleagues who were with
shirina
shirina
was very well marked as a journalist
she wear the vest that showed she was
press
she
was with her colleagues in al jazeera
car which was very well marked they just
arrived to janine which was being
invaded at the same time by the israeli
army there was no exchange of fire so
there is no possibility whatsoever that
a palestinian have shot they sharing
the israeli army always uses these
excuses to cover up the crimes they are
committing against palestinians
including palestinian journalists and
that another journalist was also shot in
the same incident by the israeli army
all indications show that shireen was
shot by an israeli sniper who was
stationed there to cover the israeli
invasion of their camp the question here
is the context in which things have
happened the context is that we are
occupied by israel we're not occupying
israel this is not a conflict between
two equal sides we are occupied by
israel the israeli army which is what
you find us is invading palestinian
cities who are under occupation like
jeanine and
committing uh
terrible crimes they have killed so far
58 palestinians since the beginning of
this year some of them were civilians
like aida zapatin who was a mother of
six children and who was almost
completely blind when she when she was
shot and left to die on the ground
bleeding to death we don't trust the
israeli investigations this is all a
cover-up approach to cover the real
reality here which is that a crime has
been committed against a palestinian
journalist with for no reason whatsoever
and uh let me say that we do not only
live in a system of occupation we also
live in a system of the worst type of
apartheid according to amnesty
international and human rights watch so
there is no way you can equate between
palestinians and israelis here and
nobody should allow the israeli efforts
to cover up this crime actually israel
should be held accountable not only for
killing
but also for killing all the other
journalists they have killed one of my
colleagues was a first aid provider
razan najar in gaza she was treating
injured people when she was shot by the
israeli army in the heart and the
israelis did not say that a palestinian
killed her and yet no investigation took
place i myself personally witnessed
similar situation in 1996 when i was in
ramallah while the israeli army was
invading and i was shocked by an israeli
sniper twice in my back
and nothing happened no investigation
nobody was held accountable
and that is happening to palestinians
constantly and around the clock this is
happening
to my apologies for interrupting you but
uh
this is happening at the time of course
as we were talking about of increased
tension um this is happening been
happening for several weeks there have
been uh killings and attacks on both
sides when we have seen situations where
people have died in this conflict and
has which has been going on
for so long there has been an almost
automatic upsurge in uh intention uh
which has led in many cases to violence
how do you think
they what do you think the reaction is
going to be in janine particularly to
this particular event
well i have a problem with the question
because you say a conflict and violence
as if the two sides are fighting with
each other in an equal battle this is
not the truth the truth is that the
tension
and the problems here and any violence
that takes place
is happening because of 474 years of
israeli ethnic cleansing of the
palestinian people
it is happening because of 54 years of
military occupation of the west bank
east jerusalem and gaza the longest
occupation in modern history it is
happening because there is a system of
oppression and apartheid practice
against the palestinian people when it
comes to ukraine
the world community says that they
respect international law and invasion
should not happen and occupation should
not take place and that's why 6 000
punitive acts and sanctions were
committed against russia
what kind of sanction was
done for israel over the last 74 years
none
this is hypocrisy and this is double
standard that should not be allowed to
continue
the real reason here of the problem and
the only solution is to end occupation
the only solution is to end the system
of apartheid against palestinian people
and now it's jeanine yesterday it was
hebrew the day before it was jerusalem
it's constant israeli oppression and
suppression of the palestinian people
this is not what i say this is what
human rights watch says this is what
amnesty international says they say that
palestinians are subjected constantly
for the last 74 years to two types of
war crimes or for
crimes against humanity sorry crimes
against humanity which is persecution
and suppression as well as the system of
apartheid and racial discrimination
without ending the occupation and ending
the system of apartheid of course we
will run from one cycle to another and
this is not a conflict between equal
sides this is a struggle a palestinian
liberation liberation struggled against
occupation if you praise an ukrainian
for resisting occupation why do you
accuse palestinians of violence and
terrorism if there is occupation
you referred to the importance of having
unbiased coverage the balanced coverage
of what is going on in the region and it
is clearly as everybody understands a
very very complex situation is there
anything that the palestinian
authorities are able to do to try to
give some sort of protection to
journalists who are attempting to do
exactly what you want which is to
provide that unbiased coverage or is
there an extent to which journalists are
have to be left on their own
what do you expect the palestinian
authority to to arrest journalists and
prevent them from doing their job the
first of all the palestinian authority
is not in charge the palestinian
authority is not in charge of janine
area when the israeli army is invading
it practically the palestinian authority
is like all of us is under occupation it
has no authority whatsoever
it really does not control any area
because the israeli army can invade any
city since 2002
when the sharon in re-invaded all the
areas that were under the palestinian
authority so i think here the
responsibilities on the israeli side and
i i do believe excuse me for saying that
again i i do believe that also your
correspondent has to
maybe educate herself a little bit more
to liberate herself from the israeli
narrative the israeli narrative is
constantly trying to put blame on the
palestinian side in this case the
palestinian authority has no
responsibility whatsoever the
responsibility is on the israeli army
which was why was the israeli army
invading
which is under palestinian authority why
the israeli army enters eugene camp and
continues to kill people constantly
why the israeli army shoots journalists
is not the first palestinian journalist
who was killed by the israeli army why
israeli army is allowed to be impunitive
and above international law why israel
is not accountable to international law
these are
my opinion the real questions that have
to be asked and one has to see the
context the conscious that palestinian
people are struggling for their liberty
their freedom their end of occupation
and apartheid against an oppressive army
against an oppressive racist regime
which is called israel
muslims secretary general of the
palestinian national initiative we thank
you for being with us sir on al jazeera